a lot has happened though since last
week's yeah many things have happened I
don't want to spend too much time on it
but booboo head is out of jail wait who
oh what's going on I'm not even calling
his name I'm calling my name booboo head
booboo head yeah oh you're talking about
yeah mr. 420 yes 420 69 has come out of
prison in his first movies renamed
himself to mr. 420 he [ __ ] goes
reggae yeah aka booboo head oh man this
[ __ ] with his address and stuff though
that's so funny
what an idiot dude that's so [ __ ]
funny
that part I will discuss and the other
part I will discuss that kind of said
this already but I don't care I was
crying at his livestream not because of
what he was saying but because of how
many you know people like Vanessa blue
check just to like comment on people's
pictures and get visibility on like
they're like yeah yeah they're getting
pay off some yeah like middle manager at
Facebook yeah and then I was dying at
all the random wanted people trying to
like you know I mean like they're just
so funny they just want a piece of that
you know who was one of them who Marcus
dobre oh nice there you go somebody sent
me a screenshot of his comment and it
was like the goat there you go yeah the
goat is back yeah dog yeah you fake six
nine in one of your music bro they yeah
just that like just said the [ __ ] in
there so jealous you know what I'm
saying like they wanted so badly to have
a little piece of that two million yeah
live that the either just anything yo do
some my favorite was wove icky saying we
missed you [ __ ] I should have like just
taking random screenshots dude so we can
just go through them cuz it's so funny
so many it's so many like Instagram
models yeah with
three million followers that nobody has
ever heard of yeah because they only get
like a hundred likes on their pictures
yeah yeah they just bought some account
[Laughter]
it'll be like you know on delay Medici
was somewhat like what the [ __ ] even is
that and her picture is golden [ __ ]
crisp like you know like there's
deep-frying memes they do that with
model pictures I've realized uh-huh when
they turn them like bronze mm-hmm and
and yeah the color is all [ __ ] weird
and washed down
it's like sepia toned yeah but just wait
but it's just their ass what do you
think of a song first of all can we we
can't it's fine yeah yeah yeah it would
be it would be some tea though it would
be what we can it would be some [ __ ]
tea if everybody screaming at their
[ __ ] oh if you knew if you knew just
no can't just no we can't but if you're
mad I feel bad that you're not getting
this little juicy piece of tea yeah
juicy little piece of team would be yeah
it resort to secrecy mm-hmm but yeah
that second verse is what the [ __ ] we
can let's just say this I should say
that's we woke a fine we wrote the song
yeah okay we wrote it for him and we put
all the gun references in on purpose
to get him back in jail yeah we're
trying to do the Society of service well
first of all Nima pointed out that they
reuse the same container from some Jason
Derulo music video did they I mean it
looks the same if not they styled it
almost identical i watch the two videos
and they're like pretty clearly
different in my opinion no the concepts
are different it's just the locator
like the okay the weird stripe room was
the same so what so for something like
that did they bring the container to his
house so let's drop it off yes and they
just shot in like the backyard yeah like
like even if okay so like the way his
address got leaked was some chick was
looking out her window and saw him
taking that picture on his deck that he
took right but how do you not hear him
blasting that [ __ ] song in the
container that just got dropped off in
his backyard dad I feel like it's way
more obvious I know he should have just
gone to a location I donno he can't he
can't he's on house arrest yeah plus
like the six women that that were in the
in that video you don't think they could
be bribed a little bit to reveal that
location bro all right I mean it it's a
it's so you saw a jack boy said Jack boy
said what's the point of even getting
out he can't he's not gonna enjoy life
you know he can sit there and say
whatever but he's forever gonna be in
this [ __ ] where did this person come
around is this person gonna say
something yeah like I don't feel yeah I
don't know any one of those people could
uh could easily give up that information
a the funny thing to me by that music
video is and I did I didn't watch it
right away but Spock was like just just
was it Spock or someone was telling me
just just watch it but and and I gave in
cuz NEMA pointing is saying that the two
videos were similar I was kind of like
uh I kind of want to watch it but I felt
like this overwhelming thing to just not
support him just to be like [ __ ] this
guy but I [ __ ] I gave in and it's so
entertaining dude it is it's so
entertaining to watch this [ __ ] happen
it is but did you feel like in the video
he has like he seemed like not confident
like yeah yeah it was kind of weird it
also looked like he might have gotten
like punched in the face or something in
jail it kind of looks like one of his
eyes is [ __ ] up did you notice that
yeah he looked swollen something about
him looks off
you look swollen dude I don't I don't
know what it is but yeah I agree he's
not as like in-your-face as he was
before like a lot of shots of him are
few and far between it's mostly the
[ __ ] giant asses yeah and when he's
at the camera it's kind of awkward yeah
he's not he's not really wrapping and
and the shots were really weird like he
like like the one where it's like
tracking with him and it feels like it's
steady and you could tell like they're
moving in a circle yeah I don't know it
just everything about it he there was a
serious lack of confidence yeah you know
what I think I think cuz I went and
looked up the house right yeah
googled the address it's like it's like
an eight hundred thousand dollar house
like in ludo Beach something like that
something like that in in you know on
the coast of New Jersey or something I
don't know right yeah okay this dude's
got like a What did he say a million
dollars on that new shark chain or
something like that yeah it's got like
nine [ __ ] chains on must be millions
of dollars he's got for Richard Mills
yeah Milly whatever on his wrists he's
four of them yeah yeah he pulls up and
buys that house in that place not no
shade I'm just saying why not like I
almost feel like he bought it purposely
cuz he knew it was gonna get leaked and
he could just move to the next place and
keep that yeah maybe I don't know I
wonder if he's actually smart you know
what happens from here I mean his fans
don't give a [ __ ] right like he has the
same fan base I think is the dobre twins
yeah I think that's the who actually
listens to him you know no his fan base
is the dobre twins yeah yeah yeah they
got my ass of crossover I bet if they
toured oh my god yeah that clean up
clean up that's that's when he could
tour he told the don't worry and little
pump is the headliner
oh now love pumps the opener Oh
oh my oh my [ __ ] stupid or dumb are you
Adam dude let me ask you a question are
you dumb or are you stupid
or are you done are you dumb I'm curious
to see what happens from here you know
if he can even release another track and
if it'll you know like like like like
did he just do well off the strength of
just being out you know what I mean and
then all these people tuned in they go
okay that's either the light or they
don't I wonder what the replay value of
this song is for people can you listen
to it again I've put it on probably
three times I I only I listened to ten
seconds of it when it when it came out
and then because we were shooting so
like I just tried to listen to it on a
lunch break and then yeah stop mm-hmm
said I listened to it on the way back
and then the [ __ ] I said oh man his
friends aren't there to write his
[ __ ] raps anymore so he doesn't know
what the [ __ ] to say that's what that
sounds like making sounds yeah like he
just like all the all the the [ __ ] that
made him him was being able to say like
scum gang and tray way and that [ __ ] is
gone yeah I don't know I think there is
a certain like quality of his music that
is lost because yeah so I all right
Anthony Fantana
Santana here thick vineeth Anton oh here
you